en l'état de notre droit celui qui a
provoqué ou tenté de provoquer la mort
de son conjoint peut sans
encombre tranquillement devrais-je dire
tirer profit des avantages matrimoniaux
insérés dans le contrat de mariage qui
n'aurait pas produit d'effet si la
victime n'était pas décédée avant lui
c'est proprement
intolérable
hubuesque
injuste
[Musique]
évidemment rappelons qu'à l'apoche de la
retraite de nombreux Français adoptent
les les avantages matrimoniaux que sont
la communauté universelle et
l'attribution intégrale de la communauté
au derniers vivant dans ces cas précis
lorsque survient le décès le droit des
successions ne s'applique pas il est
écarté par l'application prioritaire du
droit matrimonial dont les règles sont
telles que la plupart des biens
reviennent alors intégralement au
survivant même coupable de
conjugicide incroyable je dirais même
déplorable mais vrai voilà comment
aujourd'hui en France un meurtrier peut
recevoir intégralement le patrimoine de
sa victime et l'aiser ses héritiers oui
texte offre une réponse concrète à des
situations iniques car jamais jamais un
époux meurtrier ne doit pouvoir tirer un
quelconque bénéfice de son crime oui ce
texte offre aussi une réponse concrète à
des injustices insupportables subies par
les femmes de notre pays une fois n'est
pas coutume je vais donc dire merci au
groupe modem de nous avoir fait cette
proposition de loi néanmoins et c'est
sur le néanmoins qu'on va insister il me
semble que traiter la question féministe
et la question des féminicides par le
biais du patrimoine est un petit peu
légère puisque quand en 20023 il y a eu
selon l'association nous toutes 134
féminicides et que près de 100 sont des
féminicides conjugaux ce qu'il faut
faire en réalité c'est lutter contre un
système global de domination des hommes
sur les femmes qui s'appelle le
patriarcat